hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show it is always powered by icon plus so really
quickly for you so this year icon will make
a strong push into STOs if you don't know
those are security token offerings
it will fully utilize the ics token
and have synergies with icons d5 services and
its interoperability protocol always great news
from icon there um and this show as you know
is sponsored by block five so a quick shout out
to them i use them to earn up to eight point
six percent um interest on my uscc so that is
pretty insane you can also get um i think it's
up to 250 dollars i'm depending on how much you
deposit so i'm going to leave um the link for that
in the description and in the comment section and
before i bring on my really cool guest uh also
it is sponsored by coinflips so you can get 10
off transactions if you use the code which i
believe is scrolling somewhere at the bottom
so before i bring my guests on if you are
watching on youtube then please don't forget to
hit the like button and hit subscribe so you never
miss any of these fantastic guests so joining me
today is the founder of techcrunch Arrington xrp
capital which kind of gives away who it is he's an
entrepreneur a vlogger and a venture capitalist
it is michael arrington how are you doing
hello what uh what's coin flip so they're
sponsoring this do i get a cut of this
sponsorship what's going on with that part of
it damn i i don't think so to be honest but uh
what is our agreement about it it's fantastic
these companies are um are sponsoring this kind
of content and uh i mean on the screen right
now which i don't think everyone sees but i see
coin flip i also see block fi and and icon so um
it's fantastic of them to be sponsoring this so
although i don't know thank you so much yesterday
no yeah it doesn't evil doesn't it coin flip are
um an atm service basically across the states they
have i think it's around 1422 bitcoin atms so
with this discount code you can get um i think
it's around 10 uh 10 off your transaction so it's
pretty cool isn't it well it depends are there
transaction fees like 100 because now they're
only down to 90 so it really depends you know
what they're interested in not exactly no no
no no no they're they're a really good company
they're a solid company so let's do this yeah
we're done i just want to chat to you now um so
for those who don't know who you are tell us about
yourself um most of us know who you are but just
go for it uh i you know i don't like this part
uh why like well because like you i grew up
interviewing other people um sorry about that
beeping that'll stop but um so i don't like
talking about myself as much and uh but i'll do
it but i don't like it and um i don't know but i
i've always been an entrepreneur well actually i
started off as a lawyer in silicon valley and um
and then i left that and joined one of my startups
and then started my own companies after that most
of them didn't do much that was interesting but
i did finally start a company called techcrunch
that um was both commercially and
culturally successful and that that kind of
changed my career a little bit and uh and that
was started in 2005 and i sold it in 2010 and
uh techcrunch is still going strong and it's
good to see that um but after that i started a
a venture fund i did traditional venture investing
i did that for uh i don't know seven years or so
and i got a little bored with that although i
still do some of it and then i got into crypto
and now i have a crypto hedge fund
and it's called arrington xrp capital
nice so we're going to go through all of that but
now everybody knows what you do but before we go
into it you know it's been hectic on social media
at the moment um you know we connected through
social media social media is is really just like
this godsend which has transformed everything
you know given this pandemic we have it really
is a bit of a godsend but i just want to get
your views on everything that's going on you know
in terms of social media censorship um you know
trump being the platforms while he was the sitting
president what are your thoughts on all of this
so we're just jumping right into politics yeah
let's do it we're going to go back to techcrunch
i just want because we've got to talk the
most recent yeah this is hot this is fire
you know people want to hear the fire let's do it
the fire i don't know if i have a lot of fire i
i spoke out a lot about censorship over the last
month or two i'm not a trump voter but i think
that he's been treated very badly on the way out
and um and i think it's dangerous what we're doing
to trump voters in the u.s um by calling them
basically all terrorists and nazis i think is
actually encouraging erratic and uh behavior so i
think it's generally a bad thing and i've spoken
up on that but i also think it's becoming
more and more dangerous to talk about this
and i don't mean it like you know police are
going to start knocking on my door any second
because i say i'm against censorship but i
think it's just becoming not smart to do it and
i'm a libertarian i strongly believe in the right
to free speech i strongly believe in the right to
bear arms and um those aren't popular positions
to hold anymore and i'm not sure it makes much
sense to really fight those battles at this point
i think it makes more sense to focus on family and
and making individual decisions that are the best
for yourself in other words i think we're entering
a period of darkness uh in the west and i think
that period of darkness will go on for a while
so i absolutely um agree with you um i think
it's kind of i think it's kind of sad that
we're at a point whereby we sort of feel a
bit um apathetic towards it in terms of sort
of saying um you think it's a dangerous move to
to speak up about it i hear you and i feel that
just because um a lot of a lot of let's let's
call them conservative leaning accounts have lost
thousands and thousands um you know friends of
mine have lost over 20 000 followers this week
um and even my account which isn't that political
i don't think if someone could tell me otherwise
a little bit okay you do it in code
sometimes but yeah you clearly have
politics so yeah that's funny encode that's jokes
um i like that um but yeah you know i i lost about
600 um i was about 600 followers um and like it
is and you know you work so hard to sort of like
build well listen you work so hard to build
something but then say that again i'm making
fun of you like look i mean look i know there's
a lot of bots on twitter and those bots are up
to all kinds of stuff uh every once in a
while followers sort of vaporizing groups
i think that you have a strong core audience
and it will get bigger over time as you create
great content so i wouldn't worry about 600
followers a whole lot um no i know i mean i think
it's just the grand scheme like people lost over
20 000 followers and you know i just think it it's
concerning us you know like you said because you
sort of feel it's dangerous i mean i think it was
aoc who sort of said these people should be put on
a list right these um trump supporters should be
put on a list so yeah yeah yeah it's it's terrible
it's dangerous it's awful a lot of those accounts
are bots that probably doesn't matter if they're
there or not but a lot of real people are getting
silenced and for speech that is not in any way
illegal at least in the united states the uk has
significantly different laws around this and
it's always unclear to me what's legal in an
illegal speech in the uk um and i know you're i
i think you've been very public about the fact
that you'd like to leave the uk at some point um
i uh i'm worried about it but like i said there's
only you know there's only so much we can do but
i will also say this i'm not a trump supporter so
it actually is a bit of a relief to have him gone
and and part of that is it's too bad part of it is
because the media hated him the media created him
and the creator the media destroyed him and so i'm
just as mad at the media as i am at trump but the
whole thing was just a total [ __ ] show and it
to some extent i'm glad that part at least is over
and that we can move on from that but i think that
what we're doing now instead of trump the trump
show is actually significantly more dangerous
yeah i totally agree with you because i think
at least with trump we sort of understood
and i say we because when america sneezes the
whole world catches the cold um you know so when
elisa trump we know what we're getting i happen to
think with somebody like biden and kamala harris
it's kind of um i don't think they're sort of
clean and and i don't think their intentions
are as pure and i think that's actually
more dangerous um i mean what's pretty
interesting is the whole idea of like um a woman
of color and particularly a woman being the first
um being the first vice president and then
the media tell us not to focus on these things
but biden openly said that's the reason why he
hired her right like he said that yeah it's a mess
so what do we do we just focus on family well
that's what i'm doing like i i i think um
i've tried everything i've tried back in
the day i tried financially supporting
politicians i actually don't think i've ever given
money to a republican but i gave money to cory
booker and i've given money to other politicians
in the u.s and this is you can actually search all
this stuff and see who's donated to who um cory
booker turned out to be a total disaster i mean
he used to like he didn't understand i don't know
him when was it he's uh he ran cory booker ran
for president he's a senator from new jersey um
he's um oh he's dating the main thing everybody
knows before now is he's dating that famous
actress is it rosario dawson is that anyway
he um but he turned into like uh a totally like
down the middle politician to like this crazy
eyes guy who literally crazy eyes who um who says
all kinds of like nutty things and i regret ever
giving money to him like i was just trying to
support politicians that i thought could be
sane and i'm not sure there are any anymore and
so i'm not making any more political donations i
think it's pointless to speak out on social media
about this stuff because at best you're ignored at
worst you're deleted from the internet and i think
it's just better for everyone to sort of focus on
what's happening in the world and that's where
i think is interesting because if you put aside
the like civil rights issues freedom of speech etc
and you look at what's happening in the financial
world there's a lot you can do to protect yourself
i think from what these governments are doing
uh to keep themselves in power which is spend
spend spend print print print and that's where
i think that those of us in crypto are in a really
interesting place right now where we can protect
our families and protect our futures um while we
wait through this sort of this period of darkness
that i believe you know really can't be fixed um
in the short term yeah i absolutely agree i think
it is a period of darkness and for that reason
i'm like so honored and i feel so privileged
to be in crypto um because i really i know people
say bitcoin fixes this and that's just some cliche
rubbish which kind of has like a tiny bit of truth
to it but it really is sort of like an opportunity
to opt out and i think i absolutely yeah did you
just call bitcoin a cliche and rubbish no i called
bitcoin fixes this the slogan cliche and not
entirely 100 accurate but it does fix me it fixes
some things it doesn't fix everything is it going
to fix people taking away your right to bear arms
no is it going to is it going to fix um
there's so many things that people know bitcoin
um but what you can do is in my opinion i
tweeted this out the other day i think i've
got some backlash for it but just make enough
money so that you can literally just leave
like leave go to place leave the west go to
places where um you know there isn't this
like looming communism for which i sort
of feel is coming or oppression awareness
so where do you think what two questions on that
one you're not a us citizen i assume uh and so
you're not like you know u.s citizens are
particularly screwed because we can't we
can leave the u.s but we can't leave the
u.s tax system and we're the only ones
fascinating until recently by the way that you
always have to pay tax no that's why you don't
see a lot of americans working in dubai and
singapore and other tax havens because there's
absolutely no point i mean they might go there
there are some but if you live in the uk you can
go to dubai or singapore or wherever and sometimes
pay little or no tax on your income in the us you
still pay your your tax back home including your
state tax if you if you've just moved from a state
that has a lot of taxes so that's you know we're
just we're tax donkeys so we can't get away from
that now you can of course just leave the country
if you think it's a good time to leave um but i
envy you the ability to sort of hop around the
world with a with a great passport but not have
to worry about whatever taxes are hitting you back
home and only worry about the taxes of the of the
place you actually live that's really interesting
um to just on that point i look i cannot name
names but i know a guy who is american um and
he's just often his thing and he's not paying
those uh those u.s tax he's he's never he's never
even lived in the states but uh i think it's the
irs is sort of like banging on his door and he's
having an issue he's like i live he's like i was
just born there for two minutes i've lived in
the uk or wherever else he's lived all his life
who is this you're talking about i can't say
you can't i can't think so the irs will go after
him i can't say it's just a guy i know he he you
know he's just running he said the irs is already
banging on his door so well not literally but
they're emailing him they're getting his number
they're you know they're trying to get hold
of him yeah okay well anyway there is there is
one way as an american citizen to get around u.s
taxes and that's to move to puerto rico and that
loophole is still open and as far as i know it
is the only legal way to avoid u.s taxes as a
u.s citizen as you move to puerto rico you spend
at least i don't know six months a year there
and that's why a lot of crypto people there like
brock pierce and others have moved there um to
avoid u.s taxes um but that's it and then you have
to live in puerto rico which has you know it's
good and bad so so how did you get into crypto
so i've got xrp in the uh in the uh in the co in
the what's it called the description of the of the
video so let's talk about crypto i do want to get
to techcrunch in a bit but how did you since we're
on the crypto topic how did you get into crypto
well i being in silicon valley you're kind of
crypto adjacent anyway um you know we're obviously
were hyper aware of bitcoin even 10 years ago um
and eth when it first came out and was raising
money um and we made we being my partner and
i my venture fund made some bets in crypto um
and those bets are starting to you know become
liquid now but those were not tokens those were
those were just equity you know equity and
things like coinbase although i didn't invest
in coinbase i didn't have the opportunity to um
i did buy bitcoin and i think 2013 was the first
time i bought it and i think that was when
it was coinbase and uh you know so i've held
bitcoin since then um and i bought eth very
early but again i wasn't in the crypto i was
still looking for the next ubers and those kinds
of companies that we invested in in 2017 though
a lot of people got into crypto in 2017. um during
the ico boom i started to take a much harder look
at crypto and that's when i decided after doing a
couple of deals that i'd like to do it full-time
okay and so at that point that also is yxrp at
that point i started thinking about raising a fund
and i just knew the xrp people very well because
they're based in san francisco and i'd known them
for a while and so i approached them about
helping me raise that fund and that's sort
of how it all started and ripple didn't actually
become an lp in the fund but they introduced me
to people that did become lps in the fund so i owe
a lot to them for helping me get this fund off the
ground and that's sort of how it all started
but why specifically xrp though as opposed to
any other sort of asset i knew i knew people
who had large amounts of capital in xrp
and they became my initial lps now what's
interesting is at first i wasn't going to call it
arrington xrp capital i was just going to call
it something you know my last my venture phone
was named crunchbond like i was going to call
it something and actually the ripple people
who aren't directly involved actually weren't
like super excited about me calling xrp because
you know it was just unclear if i was going to be
associated with them you know legally because of
that name but i kind of pushed because i wanted
it to be called xrp capital and so they said okay
it's fine it's actually not a trademark go ahead
and do it and um and so it you know that that's
how that happened and since then our lps are not
necessarily xrp holders but that's a legacy issue
that has stayed with us and we remain extremely
loyal to the xrp community and ripple as a company
so xrp is such a hot topic um all the time um and
i saw one of your interviews i think you did with
pomp and you were sort of talking about like the
tribalism and things like that so tell me about
the tribalism that you felt you know particularly
just having xrp in the name yeah it it surprised
me so when i entered crypto again i was adjacent
to crypto in tech i understood a little bit about
what crypto was happening the tech side more so
what i wasn't ready for was the tribalism and
i i mean i kind of ran face first into a wall when
i announced the fund on stage at coindesk and i
think november late november 2017 and suddenly
there were people who loved me who i didn't know
because i was doing an xrp denominated fund and
there are people who truly hated me and wanted me
truly dead because i was doing an xrp denominated
fund and i'd never seen that before like i'd see
in tech i'd seen people like apple versus windows
type stuff before but never that kind of tribalism
and it's taken me a few years to figure
it out because it's not very logical like
it doesn't make a lot of sense to hate xrp because
it's structured differently than bitcoin or e
until you really get into the philosophies
involved in bitcoin and ethan and everything
else and so everybody in crypto hates each other
but everyone in crypto also agrees they hate xrp
and so that yes that has been like the one sort
of common theme that brings everyone together is
we all hate xrp i think that's ridiculous
and i've said why a million times but it
was surprising and it continues to some extent
and it's annoying and it's sort of a friction
and that it is what it is so yeah i think um i
i tweeted out um maybe back in like september
last year i wrote you know imagine hating somebody
because they prefer a different coin to you
and um adam back who's well known to be um you
know potentially satoshi uh-huh you know obviously
somebody very much in the bitcoin um faction um he
sort of said imagine supporting a ponzi scheme um
but not just about exit that wasn't just directed
at xrp is directed to the east was directed at um
eos as directed at um i uh pretty much
all all of them and i i can remember
the founders sort of came running in sort of
saying wow i've lost a lot of respect for you
for calling you know me a ponzi scheme yeah i mean
yeah that's every day that's twitter that's crypto
twitter and i think it drives a lot of people away
they don't want to get burned right so they don't
want to touch the hot fire and and that's too bad
because it would be nice if we could have some
philosophical differences but still agree on some
core set of principles but we aren't there yet
um and i don't know what do you think
those philosophical differences are
the differences or what are the
things that could bring us together
no like those philosophical differences
do you because i sort of think it's
there's like a libertarian undertone which sort
of differentiates the two and what do you think
differences yeah why do people hate
different coins is that what you're
asking no no between bitcoin and xrp i sort of
feel like they're the antithesis of each other
oh i think bitcoin and dollars are the antithesis
of each other i think that um i mean you have
bitcoin going this way dollars going this way i
think you know bitcoin and xrp is more like this
in terms of the angle but look i mean xrp is
a ledger based currency and it is just the way
that consensus is reached is much different
than bitcoin and because of that difference
people feel that xrp is more centralized and
because of that they feel the xrp is censorable
mutable etc whether that's true or not becomes
irrelevant because this becomes a religious war
and facts become irrelevant uh i love bitcoin i
have said and believed that bitcoin is the alpha
and the omega it is you know it is the sun and
the moon and my it is the most perfect money ever
invented or or even thought of um i also think
that eath is a very important currency and and
i believe the world computer narrative and i think
that it is exceptionally interesting and important
plays a role in bitcoin cannot and should not
play and i think xrp does the same as do other
coins and so i have no fundamental uh desire for
xrp to die of fiery death simply because it is in
some instances less decentralized than bitcoin
for the same reason i don't want eth to die
um because it is a totally different currency
than bitcoin and say has more inflation
yeah i understand so essentially they all
you know have value in different ways um
but in terms of what happened with the sec i want
to get your thoughts on that because that for some
came out of the blue for a brad garland house
apparently it didn't quite come out the blue um
so what are your thoughts on that um do you think
it's a security and also like how would you define
a security for those that don't know this is xrp
obviously yeah yeah you just asked a lot i okay so
let's start with defining a security let's
start with defining a security if you can
yeah okay well so i hate this question and i'll
tell you why like i like answering it but i hate
the question so i actually was a securities lawyer
before i became an entrepreneur that was back
a ways but i wrote a book about initial public
offerings i can't i knew i know securities law and
whether or not something is a security even
asking that question just plays into the
hands of the sec they want everybody using
their definitions to decide what isn't isn't
uh a security look we buy cryptocurrencies with
the hope of making money when they're denominated
in dollars we do that because we
don't believe in dollars anymore
is that a security uh maybe i don't know it
depends because it's not it's not just about
is it a security and then the conversation's over
it's is it a security and then if it is which is
entirely a legal definition then the sec can
really put the hurt on you and so i think it's
all securities in the sense of like we're all
buying these things because we're trying to
get into assets that will protect us from what
the dollar is doing but no are we looking at
the howie test a hundred year old sort of test
that is absolutely useless in a modern world
it's ridiculous and so we also have to look
at the fact that there's like seven other
federal organizations that are that are regulating
crypto and so is it a currency is it a commodity
how does the irs tax it how does the doj and
the fbi look at all of this and it's just a
mess and so what is more interesting than is
this a security how do we define a security is
will the u.s come up with a coherent regulatory
scheme that allows americans and people who want
to do business in america to experiment with
new business models and new type of assets
to compete on a worldwide basis and the answer
so far is absolutely not the us is only concerned
with how to tax it and how to shut it down and
so we need to fix those two problems from a much
higher perspective than is this a security or
not a security does that answer the question
yes kind of um but from you know i think it was a
wonderful answer to the question but i still well
well not exactly because you didn't answer like
do you think it's a security because it matters
it matters because although you said although
you said you know we should be focusing on other
issues like the fact that they're sort of stifling
innovation through all this tax and this and that
um but you know as as you know the founder of
arrington xrp capital there are a lot of xlp
bag holders watching now a lot of people sort of
feel that you know this could give xrp clarity
so um that matters as well the d listing of xrp on
many different platforms matters just really about
you know for people holding xrp foreign you don't
want to talk philosophy you want to talk like
down and dirty like what's actually going
to happen here and i don't have the answers
i have no idea like yeah i mean exchanges are
delisting xrp despite the massive volume of
xrp trades that were happening and a lot of
fees they're creating because they're scared
they're scared of the us government and so you
saw a nasty listing which is you know that's
it's not that surprising um when it comes to
like what what's actually going to happen which
i think is what you're really the future
is what i'd like to know look i'm hoping
that we get some regulatory clarity
from this but what i believe is the sec
wants ripple dead to put a feather in
their cap um now that's pure speculation
based on nothing other than speculation also the
sec is an entity that changes over time and is
changing right now in terms of sec chairs and so
what the sec wants over time is largely going to
be dependent on what the executive branch wants
over time and the executive branch just changed
so i have no idea i have no visibility
into what's going to happen in xrp at all
i believe the sec probably wants us to go to trial
and with those to trial we'll see what happens
um but i don't know and do i think it's a
security from the point of view of the sec no
but from the point of view of me it just doesn't
matter like what's a security what is it security
is totally irrelevant and it really just comes
down to like whether you only allow rich people
to trade an asset you allow everybody to trade
an asset and so when you look at like things like
uber i was able to invest in one of the first
rounds of uber and airbnb and pinterest because
i had wealth and had a venture fund everyday
people who are just as smart or smarter than me
also wanted to invest in those companies or
would have if they could have like looked at the
business plans like i did but the government told
them that they're not worthy that they're too poor
and so they can't make good financial decisions
on their own and so they're not allowed to invest
in that and so they don't get to make 10 000 x
returns on things like uber and pinterest and
airbnb and other companies doordash is actually
a funny one because i said no to it but all my
friends became multi-billionaires on doordash so
now it's the same damn thing the sec comes in and
they say we don't want we don't think poor people
their definition of poor are smart enough to make
decisions the rich people are and so we're going
to stop them from doing that that's evil and so
who cares what the definition of a security is
at the end of the day and we can debate that all
day although i'd probably just tune out at some
point because i don't care what i do care about
is that we should stop fraud and we should allow
people to make any decisions that they want to
make financially speaking and that's it and that's
the end of the conversation from my point of view
because i'm only looking at it philosophically
okay so philosophically speaking um you know
if this does hurt xrp do you think this is
therefore a threat to the rest of the crypto space
that the question you just asked god you're
you're good at this the question you just asked
is um is can anything take crypto down at this
point right that's really the question you asked
so xrp is decided there's a security it's decided
by court that there were there were securities
sold without an exemption or registration under
the securities act and everybody that works or
ever worked for ripple is now imprisoned
for life or put to death why not do that
what happens then i i think it's bad for crypto
but i think that crypto lives lives on and
um but i don't know what that means
for example let's say that tomorrow
the united states government said that
bitcoin is a national security threat
across the board every regulatory agency said
we're not allowing bitcoin it's illegal now
congress passes a law if you hold bitcoin you're
gonna be put to death done would that kill bitcoin
no but it would suck and it would be de facto
dead anyway because you know people would have
to decide if they want to hold this asset and be
put to death so i think the u.s government has a
has the ability to kill crypto but i don't know i
think as more and more time goes on and more and
more government representatives own crypto that
becomes a less a smaller and smaller likelihood
but no i don't think i don't think xrp whether xrp
lives or dies has much effect on crypto in general
but what's right and wrong it matters a lot yeah
i think i think it's kind of that last bit which
which kind of gets me i think what's right and
wrong absolutely does matter and whether you can
sort of take down something which is decentralized
um i don't think it's possible but in terms of um
heavy regulation taxing every single move
that you make i think that's sort of what
will make things harder like in the uk for
example they're very anti-crypto here and
we've had a lot of issues with banks and for me
it's so hard just to use things let's say like um
like crypto.com it's really hard to use
um being uk based what's what's crypto.com
is that another spot i don't know who that is no
they're not a sponsor no no no i'm completely they
don't sponsor the show i'm very transparent with
everything um no i use them they're a debit card
they're an exchange and essentially um i can send
money well i can't now i used to be able to send
my pounds into um intercrypto.com whereas
now i can't they've completely destroyed
that um because you're big gateway so i can get my
words out no it's just more you um no not the bank
it's just a wider regulatory issue um in the in
the uk um so i have to use something like revolut
and then convert to euros and then send the
euros in but converting let's just say you want
to convert like you wanna feel like let's say
um 10 grand or whatever it is converting that
from euros to pounds is gonna be a lot in terms
of like the exchange fees and whatever it is so
that's the kind of regulation that i think yeah
is more scary um well okay on the other hand look
i think that sucks and and it's terrible on the
other hand these gateways and these this friction
that banks and governments are creating is is
probably stopping bitcoin and crypto from becoming
an overheated bubble some people say it's a bubble
now we don't believe it is in any way so yeah it
sucks but in the long run these gateways and this
friction might actually help the market sort of
be a little bit more steady um otherwise you might
have seen bitcoin go to a hundred thousand dollars
you know in the last couple weeks and and instead
we'll see that maybe over the next couple of years
but yeah but also i don't feel that much pity for
you because you can get on an airplane and you can
go to dubai and you can live there in a in a in
a country or a city state that is actually like
pretty pleasant for large parts of the year and
pay no taxes i can't do that and so i feel like
you have the better deal like you can you can go
to singapore you can go wherever the hell you want
and you can pay taxes there that's pretty good
and then you can set up a bank account wherever
it is you just moved and those banks are probably
much more open to crypto than they are in the uk
the world's smallest violin is playing for you
right now yeah yeah i guess so i want to leave
the uk anyway so i have to figure that one
out um but i want to talk about techcrunch
um because um that has completely i would say sort
of revolutionized um a lot of different things and
the way um you know the way technology does the
way media covers technology and so on so this
was something that you did in 2005 so why did
you start it just yeah why did you start it uh
i mean look there's a it's a mythology at this
point i started it because i had no job i was
surfing i lived in la i spent my days surfing
and playing video games and eating burritos
it was pretty good life but i ran out of money and
my girlfriend at the time was not overly impressed
with my lifestyle and so i i realized i'd been
in and out of tech i had lived in in europe for
a while i just needed a reset and the internet
was changing at the time and it was becoming what
with hindsight is obvious but at the time was very
interesting the read write web and technologies
that allowed you um to use the internet more like
a desktop application and so you started to see
things like what has now become like gmail and
like google docs was magic back then and so you
see this sort of explosion of companies and
i just wanted to get to know those companies
and i started researching them and then i thought
why don't i just post the research and so if you
see the first you know a few weeks of techcrunch
it was just research being posted without much
like color commentary or personality but
it there was this like uh this hunger for
this kind of news because there was no positive
coverage of startups at the time like very little
and so people just like like sucked it in and it
started growing like crazy and then i just sort
of let the business become what it needed to be
interestingly we're at a similar position now so
there's tons of startup coverage now in tech that
wasn't didn't exist 15 years ago but it's all gone
very negative and i think that there's actually
like a real cry for fine negative we hate tech
tech is the cause of all problems that stuff's
fine the new york times can do it all they want
and even tech crunch to some extent has
become woke crunch and it's less interesting
but i think that there's a cryo for like hey
people just like yeah yeah we hate everything
but also we'd like to have a site that just
covers tech in like a positive way as well
and that is verboten right now but you seem like
andreessen horowitz just recently a couple days
ago decided they're gonna start doing content
that is maybe a little bit more like raw raw
tech which people are hungry for again and so
there's another just market opportunity and i
i think that people want that you know they you
need to be critical of tech when it does evil
but when there's like two women who start a new
company and they're four days old you don't need
to be super critical of them you just need to
cheerlead them on and hope that they do well
and then they can raise money and create a product
that people want and like we don't need to tell
them they're evil and part of the patriarchy and
we just don't at that point and so i hope that we
see more of like what techcrunch originally
was in the future people clearly want it
so it won't be me though because it's very hard
job like the hardest job that i've ever had is
being a journalist or a pundit and having
to be creating content every single day and
being on that treadmill of content creation every
single day was extremely difficult from a health
perspective and something i will never do again
yeah you talking about just like that news cycle
yeah waking up like in a panic like what news
did i miss right and and then and and not going
to sleep because news is still breaking and you
know and then you're not sleeping well which
means you start gaining weight which means
you start eating improperly which means you
start gaining more weight which means you're not
sleeping well and so i went from a relatively fit
35 year old to a extremely overweight 40 year old
by the time i sold techcrunch and i don't want to
do that anymore so also it doesn't pay nearly as
well as being an investor so no journalism is uh
the most one of the most stressful jobs that pay
like the least i see you right i see how hard you
work behind the scenes you're like a duck right
like you're floating on the surface you're this
beautiful duck everything's cool but like below
the seat belt you're like because i've seen it
i've seen you with trying to schedule me and
like getting you know like it's just it's a lot
of work it was probably more time getting all this
scheduled with me than we're actually spending now
and then i assume you do some kind of post
editing and all that kind of stuff too
i don't know but because i've never done this
kind of stuff but it is incredible the amount
of work you do and i understand why you're doing
it you're building your audience you're building
your personality and the myth around you
but at some point you probably will want
to do less of that or at least have teams of
people doing it for you and i hear you firstly
i really appreciate that thank you um so but the
thing is i've actually i come from a traditional
background of journalism and that was breaking
news and honestly i could never do that again
like that was torture i used to be in paris
and i was the only correspondent in paris
and that meant it was terrible oh it was so you
lived in paris and yes and it was just awful
oh yeah classy paris is awful mercy paris is just
terrible sorry if there are any parisians watching
um absolutely terrible place yeah i had the had
the the yellow best protesters all over my road
up and down smashing cart i mean that so there's
that but then because i was the only correspondent
um i was working monday to sunday i was working
um from i think i went to barcelona to cover the
catalan the catalonian riots i was working from
six in the morning until midnight oh my god yeah
i was like you were in paris you were in paris
and you had to go to barcelona for business and
you had to get up at six in the morning and work
until midnight that night happened twice oh my god
you were like what 20 or 23 or something like
that's what you do when you're that age like
do you know how many people like
would kill to live in paris and be
like i have to go to barcelona to cover something
no not exactly i'll explain why because
okay i'll explain why um i felt very
like trapped and ball and chained and
stuck basically um so i couldn't do
anything so like i had no um i'm trying to say
i for example it was okay so my family wanted
to come visit me i could say no i had to say
no everything i wanted to do i had to say no
um because if there was like a terrorist attack
for example then i had to go um i was out at like
nine o'clock one night i had like three glasses of
wine down and i get um a message that there's um
and there's a hostage situation in amsterdam
and we have to go so i kind of like had no
i just didn't like the idea that i couldn't plan
things and i had no control of my life basically
that was the problem i had no control over enough
still that was probably a great way to spend other
than not being able to see your family and not
being able to drink you know five glasses of
wine before you had to go off to amsterdam like
it would probably was i like it experience for
you for you to have right i mean like you know
so like i'm glad i went through the techcrunch
experience i just don't want to repeat it that's
what i'm saying yeah it's good to do it like you
just don't have i just like it it completely takes
away any um any um self-determination honestly
um and control over your life because you can't
you're stuck you're literally a slave to the news
and i don't want to be a slave to anything i
don't be a slave to my government i don't be a
slave to fiat currency i don't want to be a slave
to my job i don't want to be a slave to the news
yeah um so that's kind of that's kind of the way i
see that um but i had a bunch more questions um my
question was actually um so in terms of being an
entrepreneur building something so successful what
would you say some of the key ingredients are i
think the most important thing for an entrepreneur
to understand is that the entrepreneurs that ask
other people for advice rarely are successful
like i just did it i didn't know what i was doing
and suddenly i was head first into journalism and
journalists were yelling at me all the time like
crypto but not as bad because there wasn't money
associated with it but like i never asked anybody
for their advice i never asked anybody what they
think i should do i just did it and so i think the
best entrepreneurs just do stuff and they figure
it out i never read a business book about you know
how to do business i never i just i just did it
and um so i don't actually have a
lot of advice for people other than
if you have an itch scratch it like if there's
something you think needs to get built go for it
and that's easier to do in your 20s when you don't
have a family you don't have a mortgage in the
us you may have college debt but you don't have a
lot of things stopping you from doing crazy things
it's much harder when you're in your 30s
and 40s and you have a family it's just
much harder to say yes to something like
that so do it when you're young because
it costs much less for you personally to
do it and that's it that's my only advice
but what do you think about um so you said
you said you didn't ask or reach out for
help you sort of just did it but i think
reaching out for help and asking people
is like the most important thing to do because
i feel like that's the issue we're talking about
different things no no when you need help
with a task networking having people like a
support group that's fine okay what i would what
i meant by that and i didn't say it very well is
asking for advice on how to become successful
in business is in my opinion nearly pointless
and actually suggests you will not be successful
in business because you're asking other people
how to do it and the whole point of being an
entrepreneur is there's no one way to do it
and there's no set recipe for being successful
sometimes you just gotta go and you gotta fail
and you have to learn and you have to
fail some more and you have to learn
and then suddenly it it will work i failed in like
three or four startups before i did techcrunch
which wasn't even a business idea it was a blog it
was just an idea of like networking and that ended
up being where i made my first chunk of money and
so i didn't i just did it and i actually talked
to friends about it before i did it including
my then business partner and they're like this
is stupid like nobody don't create a blog like
let's go create another business so again i'm
just not the guy to ask that kind of advice for
because my only advice is just try stuff and fail
and good luck i think that people who are full of
business advice are just like to hear themselves
talk sometimes that's funny um i think you
gave incredible advice though you just said
keep trying i think that's actually the most
important thing um because i think there are
so many um people who are number one too afraid
to put themselves out there because they'll get
terrible comments i mean i don't know if you've
seen the comment section on this interview it's
it's quite something um so yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not i don't even know where to look for the
comments the comment section i've i've closed it
because there it's just a lot right so you know
that would sort of make some some people
sort of say well i don't want to do an
interview again because you know you get people
hounding at you sort of telling you all these
sorts of things um what what comment section
are you talking about on twitter or is there
oh can you not see but if you look to the
right um yeah i don't know what you can see
because i'm obviously hosting this um there's a
comment section yeah it's pretty it's pretty wild
it's pretty wild well that's fine yeah it's fine
yeah you know like it is what it is but like you
know to something like that sort of would make
people sort of say oh i'm not going to do that
again or i can see you're reading them now no i'm
not i'm looking this way comments are that way
don't care yeah okay cool um but no i think you
said the most important thing i think you have
to keep going there are so many people who are so
um they sort of feel like if somebody says no or
if you fail then that's sort of you done whereas
i i mean i put out a tweet today and i said like
the most successful people have failed more times
than those who aren't as successful as them yeah
i mean i the very first company i started so i
left my law firm and i joined the company and so
i didn't start that i just joined the company and
i was doing biz dev and sales for them so put that
company aside it was a cool company i left that
company very immaturely because they wouldn't
i was like 27 or something they wouldn't they
wouldn't promote me to svp which was like for
more 40 year olds so i'm like screw you guys
and i left i started my own company and it
was a payments company in 2000 and that company
we raised 18 million dollars in venture capital
and but then in 2000 there the market fell apart
and so we couldn't raise more money we'd spent
most of it back then it cost a lot of money using
oracle and stuff to get your apps up and running
today it's all basically free with amazon um
anyway we sold that company like 13 months after
we founded it for 33 million dollars and that was
on 18 million dollars in venture capital raised
so you think i would have made some money but
back then venture capital very standard had a
2x liquidation preference which meant venture
capitalists got twice the money out before
the founders or anyone else got any money out two
times 18 is 36 million so they didn't reach their
liquidation preference and the only thing i as a
founder could do was block the sale so they ended
up giving me like 150 dollars to sell the company
just to get my vote because otherwise the company
would have gone out of business so the company was
successful but it failed from my perspective and
i learned something and then i started another
company and that company just dead in the water
failed and then etc and so yeah i think that's
good and i do think failure is a necessary part
of being successful um very very few people are
like bill gates where they just start their one
company in college and it ends up being massively
successful mark zuckerberg is another example
very few people are like that and i luck plays
a part um but if you keep trying excuse me if
you keep trying luck will eventually hit and you
will eventually win unless you're just terrible
at being an entrepreneur i mean then you may
never be successful do you think anyone can do it
or some people do not cut out for it yeah well
some people are definitely not cut out for it
is very stressful but also um anybody can
do it in the us i think in other countries
you absolutely can't do it the social
stigma of being an entrepreneur in
europe is less than it used to be but
it's pretty significant uk less so
but um maybe that's maybe that's an age difference
i don't know i've never come across that tell me
no no the idea of failure is a bigger deal
in europe than it is in the u.s in the u.s
and europe is like oh you you started a company
and you failed um also there's french like i have
french friends here that are friend and friend
here being in the u.s that are french right
they've moved here they become very successful
entrepreneurs sometimes these people cannot stop
talking about their six-car garage house that
they've bought but when they go to france they
said they will not talk about it and they they
they pre they present themselves as very humble
and i find that infinitely interesting as to how
they they act one way in the us one way in europe
but yeah i think anybody with those caveats i
think yeah anybody can be more successful um by
being more entrepreneurial even if that just means
being entrepreneurial within your existing job
i think um you make a really cool sort
of observation about europeans um because
americans is something that i've noticed because
i'm incredibly european in my in my sort of um
in my like mentality and behavior and so on but
you guys are just more extra and more flamboyant
and louder and more excited and more when it
comes to like business you know like everybody's
because there's like this american dream right
you don't have like the british dream the english
dream it's like the american dream you know to
to build something and to create and i feel like
you have that there's more support there and
i've noticed that people um people definitely
you're right people definitely rally and support
um entrepreneurs a lot more than we do in the uk
because in the uk you know we're the brits we've
got that stiff upper lip you know we don't want to
rock the boat too much and to be that entrepreneur
you have to do something different like you did
with techcrunch so here people don't want to rock
the boat too much you know it's just a british way
i don't i mean i don't know much about the uk i've
lived there twice we did techcrunch events there
i love the country i don't know much about the
entrepreneurial mindset there but some of the
best entrepreneurial entrepreneurs in the world
have come out of the uk i think that europe is a
tougher play and then i think you've got areas
of the world that are so poor and so lacking
in infrastructure and education that they no
matter it doesn't matter what the what the
how well entrepreneurs are accepted they just
can't they just can't break out of that cycle
of poverty and that's terrible um all right
so we're coming up to the end of the show so
i just want to know do you have any um okay
to make a positive and a negative number one
what are your sort of things that you're
most proud of your achievements you're most
proud of and number two do you have any
regrets um in any of your career so far
um i mean i wish i yeah i mean the stupid stuff
like i wish i had gone all in on bitcoin in 2010
and just combining it right it's hard um one thing
that's a little different about my career as i
i don't understand this so i've seen people in
in silicon valley where i kind of came out of
it's hard that first that first win is
very hard right so you get to the first win
and and then what do you do and i what i
don't get is it takes a certain level of like
aggression to get to that first win and and
risk taking and all that i wrote an article
on tech prince called are you a pirate that was
my most read article and it's just basically like
entrepreneurs are crazy but you get to that first
level of win and then i see people basically they
do that the rest of their life so they found the
company they take it public or they sell it and
then they just work there or they become a vc and
they start making you know five million dollars a
year and then they just keep doing that for the
rest of their life i get bored doing that and
that's why like i started techcrunch i was bored
doing other stuff then i became a vc because i
didn't want to do techcrunch anymore but after
seven years of being a venture capitalist i was
born i mean i was making more money than i had
before but it was terribly boring because all
you do is you like try to get into hot deals
crypto is a whole new learning experience for
me like i the and it keeps me young like just
learning about crypto and so i don't understand
why more people don't want to like constantly try
new things particularly if they've reached the
level of success that allows them to do that and
and i i don't get it like i don't get these guys
that become venture capitalists and then they just
do that for 40 years like it's like why what you
don't get like a bigger private jet at some point
it's just got to be boring but i think they become
calcified and set in their ways and i think
breaking through that and trying new things
the whole of your life is is is a
much more interesting way to live
it's a much more interesting way to live but
it's also a much more stressful way to live
i'm with you like i i'm i'm totally agreeing
with you but i think what i've sort of
come to realize is that some people that we're
all just different and some people just like
that comfort zone like they've made enough money
like they can just chill now because you know like
you said getting that first success or however you
put it um takes risk it takes aggression it takes
stress it takes blood sweat and tears yeah why
why do that once you've made millions like just
just chill yeah i i like you know i don't know why
but i don't like doing that i like i don't know
but i want to keep learning new things so maybe
the next thing won't be money focused maybe it'll
be like i have a passion for you know animal
welfare and i i could i could always see myself
getting into that business and trying to just
you know help animals save animals and um
that probably be me spending money not making
money um but whatever it is it'll be something
new and i'll probably learn some new things and
i think everybody should be curious about that
if you if you have it in you if you don't then you
know find happiness your own way because there's
probably lots of ways to be happy in this life
so just lastly then um tech has moved a huge way
since 2005 when you started techcrunch you know
we're talking about uh cryptocurrencies i mean
that's just insane so um firstly did you expect it
to sort of really just explode the way it did and
then secondly where do you expect you know how
do you expect it to look in 10 years i thought
you're going to hate that question but let's talk
about crypto what i didn't quite understand the
tag just tech in general technology like you know
social media crypto all of it it's just exploding
in every possible way so did you expect that um
oh yeah i expected look if you if you look at
tech from a from a fundamental standpoint you've
got you've got you got microchip like processing
speeds and you have data bandwidth and so
we're doing a good job of getting data like
bandwidth speeds up around the world um but it
still could be so much better and chip processing
speeds have largely plateaued in any real way
and until there's a major breakthrough we're
not going to see like the next level of stuff that
is truly magic i mean if you'd shown an iphone to
somebody 100 years ago they would be their brain
would explode because it looks like magic to them
what is what's the thing that they could be shown
to us today that would make our brains explode and
you can imagine what those things are like fully
immersive um virtual reality you know uh okay 3d
printing teleportation would make a lot of changes
the destruction of the soul so i'm not a big fan
of teleportation from a star trek perspective but
yes these kinds of things where are we like we
need like is that like are we going to slow down
it's like the kind of innovation we're seeing in
10-year period now is we're going to see over 100
year period in the future and that just comes down
to whether or not we see scientific breakthroughs
that can keep up with our expectations and that's
way out of my area of expertise but i've been
funding some companies that are doing pure science
and and i hope that i hope that we continue to
see gains there that can help us in other areas
nice so any last words before we uh before we sign
off and say thank you to our viewers we've got a
lot of views i i'm a big fan of yours i don't know
exactly when i started following you but uh ever
since then which was sometime early last year i
think you know i just enjoy you know listening
to you on on your podcast and reading you on
twitter so i'm i'm just honored that you finally
uh agreed to bring me on the show and uh and if
there's anything i can ever do to help you um
you know just let me know thanks so much i really
appreciate that i really appreciate that um that
that means a lot kind for someone who's uh done
so much you know so i really appreciate that so
thank you so much for coming on the show um it's
been great um thank you to my sponsors and thank
you everyone for listening um if you haven't
please subscribe to my youtube channel and
hit the like button so we can continue to get
such brilliant guests guys thanks so much bye